[Music]
all right we are back let's go to megan
in canoxville tennessee what's up megan
hey how are you doing i'm good how are
you in knoxville you all having fun
yeah i'm enjoying it very cool just a
few hours down the road from me what's
up how can i help
well i have a question related to family
boundaries specifically with my
grandmother we just had a call just like
that this is gonna be the boundary show
all right so bring it on what's up
okay so i am a senior at the university
of tennessee and when i started college
here
um i started calling my grandmother
and it became an everyday thing so i
have called her every day for the past
three years or more
and you know we've gotten really close
because of it it's been good why'd you
start calling but
we started getting closer that summer
before i left to college okay and then
it was kind of like positive
reinforcement like she was very happy to
be receiving these calls she would make
comments to the family
even comparing like megan calls me every
day or hannah never called me
yes you became the golden granddaughter
are you all in the same town we all live
in different cities
so she lives uh an hour away from me i'm
actually in that town right now okay to
the east yeah okay all right so
okay so you've been calling three every
day for three years
yes most married couples don't talk to
each other that often so well done all
right so
so moving forward
i have begun to realize that it is less
of a good you know
call and i'm enjoying it it's more of
this obligation and like a check box
like i'll plan my day like ah i gotta
call her at this time and i'll try to
plan it um just so i can make sure that
i said okay i did call her because i
have missed a couple of times and when i
have
she will remember and she makes a point
of it like oh yeah i know you didn't
call me yesterday i was thinking you
were leaving me to the side or something
like that um
so wow that's such a clean
what a great that's a great uh
power move it's a great guilt trip move
well done
so i'm i'm trying to wean off of it
because i'm applying to grad school is
that a good way to say it i mean
feed off of anxiety meds you wean off of
of calling grammar
that's right yeah
and because i'm moving on to a different
phase of my life i'm applying to grad
school right now
i have a new relationship things are
getting a little bit busier
and it's not that i wouldn't have time
to call her every day you know if you if
you want to do something you can make
time for it but i don't know if i want
to
call her every day
and now i just feel like
she has this expectation and she's even
made comments about my sister who
doesn't call at all like well at least i
can count on you i know you'll call me
every day and i've kind of said you know
grandma sometimes
in the future i might not be able to and
she's like well i sure hope not i hope
that doesn't happen yeah i guess i'm
just thinking forward to the future you
know if i have a family and kids and
stuff am i gonna be able to call my
grandma every day
so i'm gonna free you from this you
don't have to feel guilty for not
calling your grandma every day
thank you
you're free be free
um i do think a
[Music]
a
[Music]
um what's the right way to say it
some sort of boundary conversation
would be helpful
and
just know that any sort of boundary
conversation is going to come with
somebody who receives the boundary
conversation
really
banging their head up against that
boundary to see if it holds or not
and so if you say hey grandma we're
gonna go down to once a week
i'm entering into a bonker season of my
life we're gonna get onto once a week
i'm gonna call you every sunday at
whatever
you provide yourself some clarity you
provide her some clarity and then
she's gonna get upset with you
she's gonna say well i don't know what i
did to hurt your feelings or i don't
know why you don't love me anymore
and that's where you this is gonna be so
hard but you as the grown-up have to
know that that those kind of comments
are not about you those are that's about
her
that's her choosing to try to exert
power over a young woman
um
in the in the counseling we call it the
one down position
instead of saying like like your dad
would might one-up position say you will
call me every day or i cut off your cell
phone because i have bigger muscles than
you and bigger paychecks
grandma in the one down position goes
oh oh oh okay i i thought you loved me
but if you don't then um
okay
i hate to be a burden to you and i know
you're
i thought i was more important than your
boyfriend in in school but if i'm not
then that's great that's one down
position nonsense
see yeah
um here's what really sucks
you can't control grandma
and you have to decide
am i gonna give her permission to speak
into every corner of my life
or is she going to be my grandmother
yeah i think
in the way my mind works i'm like okay
if i just plan this out perfectly nope
nope i can control her reaction but
that's not the case i can't no you can't
the best way you can do is be honest
with her treat her with dignity
with respect and if you set up a new
boundary you uphold your into the
bargain so if you say i'm gonna call you
every monday at 8am or whatever then
build that into your world
and
or if you say hey instead of calling i
want to start writing letters back and
forth that might be a good thing let's
start mailing each other letters i don't
get any mail
i'm running out of time where i can't do
these phone calls anymore or like you
said
i don't want to be on the phone all day
every day um i'm working on talking on
the phone less but i do want to write
letters to you and i do love getting
letters because i i don't get them and i
know you're still in college you may not
even know what a letter is um i like
letters i actually just sent out
christmas cards i'm busy yeah imagine if
you got a christmas card every week
they're the best write each other
letters um but i'm trying to think of
maybe something like that
um but at the end of the day
this has become an area of esteem for
you and even though you don't like it it
kind of feels awesome when she talks
trash about her other grandkids
including your sister
and you're the best one it's kind of
awesome and it kind of is lame too
and
it's time to let that kind of stuff go
it just no this is gonna hurt she's
gonna make you feel really guilty and
you're gonna feel guilty
because she doesn't really have many
people is the thing she doesn't that's a
choice that she's made or yeah
that's a choice that she's making on a
daily basis
and i hate that
does your mom call her or your dad
that's the thing that's where this is
it's my mom's mom my mom also has
since we moved here to tennessee for the
past i don't know 10 years she has
called her every day too
um
and then it kind of so she'll you it's
my mom and me that call her every day
those are the real two people that she
has interacting with her on a regular
basis so in a weird way you know still
have my mom
yeah sorry mom you gotta call twice a
day you are basically your grandmother's
anxiety medication is that fair it could
be yeah um
yeah yeah that's not your job
your job is just like i've noticed that
i've started to resent it a little bit
there you go and that ultimately that's
where this all ends up is instead of
feeling guilty about not calling you
call and you call and you call even i
don't have time even i don't want to
even when i've got other things that
really need to get done
and then you land in resentment world
and then
like you start to not like your
grandmother because you make it her
fault that you can't not call
that's exactly what it is and sometimes
i even notice myself getting so annoyed
with her for nothing just because i'm
like oh yes because you're you're in
resentment remember this when you get
married because this will show up again
somewhere
are you going to marry this person
you're with
i hope so oh gross are they cool
yeah
okay so there's gonna be things that
drive you crazy about them and
you can feel guilty about saying
something and just choose to not say
anything like ah i really drives me
bonkers when you leave your shoes out or
can we all just agree to put our shoes
up
or i'm just not going to say anything i
don't i know they're working hard and i
don't i'll i'll feel guilty and then
that turns into resentment so just know
choose guilt over resentment every time
every time and choose dignity over all
of it right so being honest with your
grandmother letting her know what's up
choosing i'm not gonna let her
make me feel bad for
first setting boundaries up in my life
i'm just gonna make that choice and just
you have to practice if she does get
upset about it let's let's back that up
100 chance she will
okay a thousand percent chance she will
there is no way to manage the soft land
of this thing
she's gonna view it as a breakup and as
though she is in your way
and you have chosen grad school or some
some romantic interest or some dog or
some pet or that you're choosing these
things over her she's forced herself
into this binary it's me or everything
else which is not how any relationship
should be
but
you know who else does that children
young children
daddy don't go to work you should stay
here and play i gotta go to work well if
you loved me you'd stay home and play
no if i loved you i'd go get a job so
that you can eat you're right
and
such it is
in an ideal world your grandmother says
you're going to grad school that's
incredible you're not going to have time
to talk to me every day let's talk once
a week
and i want to hear all about it and i
want to hear about this knucklehead of
person you're in love with and all those
things that's an ideal perfect world
because that's a grandmother who's
interested in your success and your time
and trusts you to be a good steward of
your life
unfortunately we don't all get that
oh i'll pray that that is the answer but
i don't think that's going to be knowing
my grandma 100 chance it won't be
100 chance
but
you're still worth it anyway is that
fair
yeah all right so
get your boundary lined up maybe go
ahead and tell your mom too this is
coming hey i'm gonna have a talk with
grandmother
um
and maybe write a letter too and mail it
so that she can know how exciting it is
to get a letter from you or i don't know
or something
but yeah there is no way to softland
this one just be honest be direct be
treat your grandmother with dignity and
then when she starts her
guilt tripping choose
in your heart to say
that's her
processing her loneliness that's her
processing her grief
that's not mine to own she's a grown-up
she's a brilliant
strong grandmother and she's making this
choice
and maybe she will get some buddies she
can hang out with every day that'd be
even more awesome